hi I'm Ryan I'm Jerry we're gonna be
watching the trailer for the raid 2
redemption I think is what it is
no the first one is the raid redemption
what's this one I think it's just a raid
- okay very clever with their titles
I've actually never seen the first raid
but if this trailer excites me
I'm definitely renting it because
everyone already says it's like the most
amazing thing ever
yeah I've heard it's really good yeah
especially for action
I'm surprised we haven't watched it yet
we're bad people subtitled getting
really blame us ray - Bernard ulch
of its Brendel I don't know all right
let's get our raid on Sundance liked it
it was the official selection namaste
Hare Rama say @osha Papa about say
villain say be selfish a Baba Baba
Yaga's a loose shoe cutting a chicken
breast even Tresa the non of Warner
cutting in general
maryska community rules under Captain
Kalki Tanaka Panther Team Rubicon Hill
chlorophyll Azula sekarang in ecotype
Akira under kohake the penguin unknown
go to put meat cleaver digipan mucho an
animal Safari better than Jeff incident
0.1 Loomis Otesaga redundant cat idea
Omar look of insanity a bluebottle ill
attain the wrong something opinion are
you here to buy this is like many others
technician impossible portion
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
way to burn brendan fraiser ran it makes
you want to watch that fight dude it's
not over
I wish I knew what was not over yet I
know something is not over yet and now
when I watch the first rate I will know
something is not over that makes me want
to watch the first one so I can watch
that oh it's awesome that looks totally
I would watch it if I didn't have time
to watch the first rate
yeah no serious yeah it looks like some
of the coolest action I've seen beyond
action but like it looks like very
dramatic and very moving you know the
music's beautiful what that is the music
and movie lor you know it's just shot
wonderfully yeah right I mean I've heard
the first rate is is not like a story
heavy movie like it's yeah here it's
like a non-stop action for yeah so I'm
wondering what there's the thing is
gonna be this time around but regardless
it looks awesome yeah well they can't
just repeat themselves you know they was
instead of just going all action you
know having a lot story this time yeah
with with enough action to please really
first one yeah let's watch this with no
subtitles and see if we can understand
it